what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty big and
exciting news about the Fantastic Four
the Fantastic Four are going to be
coming in 2025 right after Deadpool 3
kicks off phase six however it does look
like we're about to learn a lot more
about the Fantastic Four pretty soon in
fact our first look at the Fantastic
Four might not actually be that far away
right now we're about two years out from
the film so don't expect a trailer or
anything like that anytime soon however
pre-production has begun and Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios has been
working on this movie for a very long
time already this movie is Kevin feige's
baby he wants this movie to be perfect
which means he has been working on it
for a very long time but we've recently
got some news that quite a bit of work
has been done for the movie all the way
to the point to where we have official
concept art that's already been done not
linked to the public yet but it has been
shown to some people over at Marvel
Studios people who aren't really that
involved with the movie and a pretty big
Fantastic Four fan has said that the
movie is going to be pretty epic and
that man is Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania director Peyton Reed the person
who helped develop the original
Fantastic Four film in 2001 and 2002
before the movie officially came out in
2005. he was also supposed to have a
Fantastic Four movie of his own that
never happened but he himself has now
approved of what Marvel Studios is doing
with the Fantastic Four right now in the
MCU and a recent Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania interview with somos Geeks
he talked a little bit about the
Fantastic Four in fact he has said that
he has seen artwork of the new Fantastic
Four team and in regards to this he said
I've seen between you and me only I've
seen initial artwork for the Fantastic
Four stuff around the Marvel offices and
it's going to be great this is awesome
because Peyton Reed has a deep love for
the Fantastic Four he is wanted to write
and direct his own Fantastic Four movie
for an extremely long time over 20 years
but now he said that he's actually happy
that somebody else is doing it but since
he is such a big fan and wanted to do it
himself his approval of what Marvel
Studios has currently planned means a
great deal if a man who has wanted to
write and direct his own Fantastic Four
movie for over 20 years says it's going
to be good then it's probably going to
be pretty dang good and this shows us
that Marvel is really moving with the
Fantastic Four now there have been so
many casting rumors over the past
handful of months rumors that have said
that the Fantastic Four have been cast
some that say that they haven't been
cast yet but they haven't narrowed down
but now if we think about what Peyton
Reed said that he's seen official
artwork for the movie This Means that
Marvel Studios might have already
actually cast their Fantastic Four team
now of course it could be artwork with
no specific person just inspiration
taken from the comics but like I
mentioned considering the fact that
Kevin feige has already been working on
this a while and he felt okay to show
Peyton Reed what they were working on
even though Peyton Reed has really no
involvement in the project whatsoever it
means that Kevin feige is confident
enough to show a true fan of the
Fantastic Four what he's doing and this
probably means that they're a little bit
further on than Peyton Reed is telling
us and there is also the possibility
that there is some connection with the
Fantastic Four and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania after all Nathaniel Richards
AKA King the Conqueror is a descendant
of Reed Richards Mr Fantastic so there
already is a connection between the
Fantastic Four and King the Conqueror
plus not to mention there have been a
ton of theories and speculation stating
that the quantum realm is going to have
a pretty big connection to the Fantastic
Four in the comics the Fantastic Four
have a pretty big connection to the
negative Zone but for the most part the
Negative Zone in the comics is
essentially the quantum realm on the MCU
that's kind of how they're portraying
the quantum realm so there is a slight
possibility and I mean a slight
possibility and it's just speculation
not trying to get everybody's hopes up
but there is a slight possibility that
the Fantastic Four could appear Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania even if they
are simply variants of the true main MCU
universe's Fantastic Four actually rumor
has it and according to some plot leaks
out there if they are true we are indeed
going to be seeing some variants of some
characters that we know show up in
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania which
does make sense because Kang essentially
has infinite amount of variance that's
how the multiversal war started and
quantumania is kind of going to be about
variance in fact in the trailer we have
seen a scene that shows us many
different Ant-Man variants it looks like
we've even seen one die in fact it looks
like we've seen one die just like Mr
Fantastic died and Multiverse of Madness
turned to string cheese and it's also
confirmed that there are going to be at
least two variants of King the Conqueror
in quantumania in fact I believe in the
trailer we have seen more than one
variant they've shown us a few different
sites of Kang and you can notice slight
differences in them what we know is that
there's going to be a king the Conqueror
essentially trying to take over the
Empire of another other Kang however
that Empire is said to have variants of
the heroes that we know and love working
for him so these variants won't exactly
be heroes since they'll be working for
Kang now we could see variants of the
Fantastic Four working for Kang but of
course I would assume these aren't the
main Fantastic Four that are going to be
coming in 2025. I doubt they're going to
introduce that team in quantumania
however we could be introduced to let's
say one member of the Fantastic foreign
quantumania we know that Bill Murray's
character is essentially going to have
somewhat of a little kingdom of his own
he's definitely somebody who is in
charge of some things and perhaps one of
the people working with him could be a
member of the Fantastic Four I'm gonna
guess that we'll probably see a variant
of the Fantastic Four before we see the
true Fantastic Four even if that is just
one member this is kind of like what
happened with the thing supposedly being
in She-Hulk I don't really think they're
going to introduce an individual member
of the Fantastic Four before they
introduce them as a team now keep in
mind fine though Kevin feige did come
out and say that the Fantastic Four
reboot film will not necessarily Be An
Origin story so it is possible that the
Fantastic Four could have already gotten
their powers possibly from the quantum
realm and could have already gotten out
of the quantum realm we know that Janet
Van Dyne got stuck inside of the quantum
realm and she emerged from the quantum
realm with essentially powers like
people have been speculating for a long
time the Fantastic Four could get their
powers from the quantum realm and being
stuck inside so even if we don't see
them there could be a slight little
mention maybe they mentioned something
about four people who develop Powers
maybe Kane the Conqueror had to fight
the Fantastic Four Once Upon a Time
inside of the quantum realm perhaps the
Fantastic Four escaped by stealing
something from Kang the Conqueror after
all we do know that Kang is going to ask
Ant-Man for a favor and that favor is to
steal something from the other king the
Conqueror and a question I have is how
exactly did King the Conqueror lose what
he needed what we're all assuming is a
power source to power his time chair how
did he lose that well originally
Nathaniel Richards develops his time
travel device based off of previous
works from Reed Richards it also could
be based off of Victor Von Doom's
technology the comics have kind of
reworked that but it is kind of a good
setup for the MCU because in the comics
Nathaniel Richards goes back in time to
ancient Egypt and he rules over Egypt
until the Fantastic Four battle him and
defeat him and he leaves this could
combine the Fantastic Four and Nathaniel
richards's comic book story Into The
quantum realm and in the MCU and I think
would be a really cool story about how
at least one variant of Kang got stuck
inside of the quantum realm he could
have traveled there with his time travel
chair but then the Fantastic Four who
were also stuck there using their own
time travel devices font King and
possibly took what he needed to power
their own time travel device and they
escaped that way stranding Kang inside
of the quantum realm this would be a
pretty cool way to kind of introduce the
Fantastic Four not really showing them
but just kind of mentioning them since
they are are going to be coming up in
two years and seeing as how Peyton Reed
has seen concept art for the movie it
does make you wonder if he has seen this
concept art because some version of the
Fantastic Four are going to be in
Quantum Mania or maybe Kevin feige just
chose to show him because he's been
wanting to make his own Fantastic Four
movie for years either way it looks like
the Fantastic Four are well underway
since they have concept art done and
Kevin feige is showing it to people so
I'm sure it won't be long until we start
to see some things come out from Marvel
Studios giving us more hints and more
updates about the Fantastic Four but let
me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and subscribe stay up
to date on all the latest news for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof